this is what I'm training you to be like
the Four Horsemen of the [ __ ]
Apocalypse Adolf Hitler might be the
highest performance guy that ever was
born on the planet when you decide that
you really want to invoke permanent
change you start playing to win all the
time me motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation
he used an Pena and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one practice success before you
are successful and to practice success
before you're successful one of the
stories and I know Peter remembers that
before I had any money I used to go to
the rolls-royce dealers and sit in the
cars and smell the leather touch the
leather okay and these days this is 40
years ago I went to million dollar
houses and my wife and I would walk
through the house and they'd say one of
your parents getting here kids no we are
the buyers okay and to get used to it
and that's the reason the castle is so
effective and the reason I stopped
giving outside seminars is that the
success rate is almost five times
greater going to the castle having a
butler wait on you dressing thinking
more of yourself because self-esteem is
the key to high performance if we feel
good about ourselves and we hang around
with people the average of the five
people that we are mostly around is who
we turn out to be rule number two know
what you're passionate about follow what
you're passionate about what you love
you if it's not work if you love what
you're doing okay
most people when I say they're living
quiet lives of desperation is because
they're involved in the business or
and/or a job that they don't enjoy they
don't they're not passionate about okay
so if you found something that you're
passionate about then it doesn't matter
if you work three hours a day or 13
hours a day that's where you start and
most people aren't there most people
have to find that rule number three
surround yourself with great people but
does that look like your group yeah it
doesn't look like your group I mean in
no way shape manner or form you know
maybe if we had a bunch of bunny rabbits
running there or it's unbelievable but
again you are who you're hanging around
with you know
and as Oprah Winfrey says and which I
talk about a lot is that you want people
with a like mind and that are better
than you smarter than you more
intelligent than you to get on your bus
don't be so concerned about what you're
gonna do with those people but you want
to you know the joint brain is you know
there's nothing the joint brain
collective brain or brains can't
overcome and I give the example of the
atomic bomb Manhattan Project and they
were put together and they were told we
need we need to develop a weapon of mass
destruction which they didn't call it
that back in those days in the middle
40s to end the war in the Pacific and
they did they didn't know if I was
implode or explode but they did but if
you're if your team doesn't look like
that then you should I won't say you
should give serious thought you should
just change rule number four perfection
equals paralysis perfection equals
paralysis okay so debt you you can never
make a perfect to say no no if you left
it the engineers no car would ever come
off the assembly line no car would ever
come off the assembly line and I've been
in business with enough engineers I can
tell attest to that with my hand on my
heart they'd still be trying to try to
make it better and the internet business
is very much the same the internet kids
want a test and test and test and they
would want the the landing page to be
this and roll it out the great thing
about the Internet is your results are
instantaneous and you can make changes
instant correct I mean if something that
I'm over seen at a Concorde level 60,000
feet doesn't work in two days can it
forget about it move on and today at our
meeting now the young kids are we ran a
three days sir and we closed it down and
they are thinking I'm gonna ask why I
said no that's fine next because without
them making mistakes and without them
being allowed to make the decision they
never get any better and in 95 percent
of the time I know
probably better than they do but we're
never been you know we're never going to
be able to know everything or have them
know everything unless and they will
never know everything but unless they
makes mistakes and make mistakes and get
comfortable with making mistakes also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below but Nolan does
know initially upfront you have to try
you have to swing at the plate a kid
like you you had to keep track of seven
days a week 24 hours a day what you do
rule number five focus on the few not
the many mousekewitz the famous Prussian
general said focus on the few not the
many and the when biggest common the
most common air that I see and
successful reasonably successful
business men and women are that they try
to do too many things and focus on the
few not the many rule number six believe
passionately most of you lack the skills
to sell your vision with clarity because
you don't practice and and the travesty
really is is because you don't believe
enough in it
you just don't and if what you're trying
to finance isn't your dream isn't your
vision I mean the banker or the person
on the other side of the table sees to
it clearly they know just absolutely
definitively because at the end of the
day they want to feel down deep inside
warm-and-fuzzy that this person or this
person will do whatever it takes to pay
me back the money and if you don't
believe with all your heart then you're
not going to you know go that extra mile
that's what they want to believe and
most of you don't believe passionately
and what you're doing and that's why
it's very easy for me to say you got to
turn the damn key just walk away and
look for something that you can
passionately believe in is that so
difficult rule number seven what gets
measured gets accomplished another one
of my great influencers is Toyota Toyota
automobile he wrote a book called the
Toyota way and he said constant
supervised stress constant supervised
actually I think he used the word
organized stress what does that mean it
means keep people accountable just like
Peter sage says right keep people what
get measured gets accomplished and I
have signs in most of the business I'm
involved in when you walk in the door
that's a big thing about as big as that
paint painting they're what gets
measured gets accomplished right without
measurement you're just fooling yourself
rule number eight just do it okay the
question is do you the person ask me the
question have what it takes to do what
bandit and you never know but Nolan does
know initially upfront you have to try
if the swing at the plate you have to
you know take risk you have to be
willing to sacrifice you have to be
one of the make commitment they just do
it I keep saying that I mean it's it's
simplistic it sounds like I'm well you
know I'm not having thought the question
too but that's not the point at all the
point is after 21 years of coaching and
after almost 45 years of killing us
myself and being high performance person
in six decades I realized you just gotta
do it
rule number nine be extremely positive
but I'm high on life
okay okay and that became popular in the
60s when everybody was going I was D
right okay
but I'm high on life I always have been
high in life I've got a lot of energy
the same energy of today as I did 30
years ago but you're naturally a
positive person I'm a hundred percent
positive I don't guys you know the most
contagious thing in the world isn't a
positive action it's a negative thought
hmm a negative thought and because you
can that can grow geometrically and kill
deals kill you even companies for that
matter and so but I'm extremely positive
rule number ten love yourself and I tell
people one of the things that you need
to do and I'm stealing my thunder is you
need to be more selfish me you as an
individual Jesus all right
I'm not enough no no nobody is okay
because you can't love somebody or love
what you're doing unless you love
yourself and most people and I've got a
whole section on this when they look in
the mirror Brian they don't like what
they see I'm bald
I'm two wrinkles my tits are too small
my kids are too big my ass is too thick
my yeah I've got what do you call when
you get Pippa acne I've got this you
know my my shoulders aren't wide enough
you know
nobody likes nobody not nobody but many
people don't like what they see when
they look in the mirror so you got so
you get them to to be more selfish and
to like themselves more yeah oh yeah we
don't want life love love
rule number 11 focus Warren Buffett and
Bill Gates simultaneously said one word
focus that's it focus and in in in the
many years that I was a hundred percent
focused
and I created a lot a lot of wealth for
myself I only thought about one thing
and that was it and I'm not I'm not
saying that it's easy because if it were
easy
there'd be like a qlae shop on every
corner like Starbucks my market is
700,000 people out of seven billion if
you want to be me seven hundred thousand
out of seven billion I don't know what
fraction that is but it's not a very big
one that's it there's seven hundred
thousand people on the planet that can
commit to the focus the laser beam focus
of the gates Trump's Ellison's
etc if you if you want to if you want to
create generational wealth generational
wealth is wealth that you make in 20 to
25 years because depending on who where
you google it a generation age of 20 or
25 years we we do that and I've taught
and I did it myself
how to do it in four to seven years and
the in virtually throwing everything
that you've learned or read out the
window but its focus and not that many
people can stay focused
in fact that's an understatement that
gross understand hardly anybody can stay
focused rule number 12 make some money
unless we build the right foundation I
mean the house will be wobbly and it'll
be you know you got it we got to build
the right foundation and for the most
part most people in this room and most
people listen on YouTube have to come to
the realization as sad as it is that you
have pissed you have urinated heretofore
up until this morning your entire life
down a very simple that's it
if you want to create massive wealth if
you just want to be a happy slappy
housewife from
Dundee or happy slappy bimbo from
Toronto or a happy slappy guy who goes
to the Little League games and basic
Arizona then that's okay
but if you want to create some money and
money's not everything but if you don't
money think money can buy happiness you
don't know where to shop you can get
money and then go save the world and get
money and save the forests in Brazil you
make money and go save global warming
which I don't believe in you guys I mean
and save that the pig kids in by app or
know that you but without money you
can't save a thing don't you understand
don't do it it's on YouTube understand
that until you make some shekels until
you make some coin you can't help
anybody
because if love got the job done you
wouldn't all be up rule number 13 pushed
through failures we have two bank
accounts like I said earlier a financial
bank account an emotional bank account
and where we all fail myself included is
emotionally I get afraid you know but
it's not what happens to you in life
it's how you react to what happens to
you in life but I just push through I'm
so used to success now you know I'm not
blowing smoke up my owner I'm so used to
it now it's my fact pattern I mean it's
mine nobody's interested in the failures
I've had last year I had tried 22
different things that failed but I tried
- there were big successes so nobody's
interested in the oh I think we'll try
this and it didn't work I think I'll try
this and it didn't work
rule number 14 find a mentor the system
that I've seen that works which is very
much contrary to all the other success
guys which I don't consider myself is
the mentorship or if somebody mentors
you so you find somebody it is where you
want to be and has accomplished all this
either man or woman and then you find
them and you come to them with your
dream and your passion and and and
assuming the chemistry is right and it's
not always right
the rest is history it's like the Tyson
Gus D'Amato deal you know yeah okay
Tyson by accident the greatest respect
Mike found that guy when he was 13 14
years old when he was you know doing all
kind of ugly things not dissimilar to
myself but the same age and and Gus
mentored him until diamond and as that
in you know Mike will admit I guess I
don't know I've never talked to him
about you know when when Gus died and
all that all that stuff happened
he made some poor to some very poor
decisions so you got to find that person
and you don't just you know you're not
just gonna find him you know walking
down the street on the high street I
mean you have to make a concerted effort
to find somebody that you that you you
look up to and normally that person is
several years older than you but they're
successful in what you want to do rule
number 15 stop wasting time if you had
to keep track of seven days a week 24
hours a day what you do you would be
shocked astounded overwhelmed or as they
say in Britain gobsmacked how much time
you waste and I make them keep track of
every minute of the day every minute of
the day and it's not easy it's not easy
and when you find it out the I have
people that have come to the seminar
it's spent 20 hours a day walking in the
fresh air in meditating 20 hours a week
excuse me not a day 20 hours a week and
they don't get anything done and they
don't feel relaxed rule number 16
fulfill your potential what takes you
off what like what really sets you off
right now you mean irritates me
irritates you pisses you off that man's
greatest burden is unfulfilled potential
man's greatest burden is unfulfilled
potential and I say when I look at the
audiences and I know that maybe only 1%
are going to achieve their potential
not fully
I've still haven't fulfilled my
potential but unfulfilled potential is
man's greatest burden and it breaks my
heart because I know what you kids are
capable of I know I've had kids with
Atiq to 180 IQ that I mentored that have
that have done big big deals actually
the ad IQ did better than the hundred ad
IQ okay and I know what they're capable
of and I know how ten million or 100
million or whatever the number is
changes lives and the and then all of a
sudden you know you believe that you can
walk on water
you believe that you can take a loaf of
bread and feed however mean he was
supposed to have fed and make water into
wine and when you believe at sea the the
the true test of a leader is when you've
trained other people to be leaders it's
in you kids I mean you can do it if you
want it bad enough and you stay focused
and you're willing to maintain that
commitment rule number 17 work hard
my dad was a workaholic he was a cop but
he was a workaholic when he retired from
the LAPD after 28 years he had 700 plus
days they wrote him a check for he never
took a day off 728 years he never took a
day off it was always at work and the so
I saw that and I say you know and
although and then he went on he went
with the CIA and he became a college
professor but I saw him work hard and
the and I aspired to follow my dad and
my dad's footsteps as far as that was
concerned I turned 16 which is when you
can get a permit to work legally and I
got a job as a box-boy which they don't
have anymore where you put groceries in
the ladies bags and you help them out to
the car the first month
that I worked was August 1961 when I
turned 16 so my birthday is the 10th so
I worked 20 days 21 days my paycheck for
that cuz I just happened to look it up
was 241 bucks so I worked about 240
hours in 20 days you you got a headache
you don't want to work I'll take your
shift you you want to go to the beach
I'll take your shift okay so my first
month that I first 20 days I work I was
averaging ten twelve hours a day when
I'm 16 years old I realized as Elan musk
recently said if you work 80 hours a
week and another guy works 20 40 hours a
week unless you're something's wrong
with you you're gonna get twice as much
done I I discovered that rule number 18
take action prayer is great
contemplation is great but if you don't
take action action action all the rest
is wasted and what the kids today I have
trouble with they canal reading a book
to take an action all and I'm not saying
you shouldn't read cuz I've read the
classics I've read Shakespeare and you
know all that stuff but it's not taking
action taking action is pulling the
trigger going out and making something
happen and even if you fail rule number
19 have high expectations I'm 15 pounds
overweight my doctor said and he said
you know if you wanted to be in perfect
health which everything else is perfect
my health I'm well you should lose 15
pounds and I said I'd have to give up
three or four martinis and a bottle of
wine every night I'm not wanting to do
that it's I know what it takes and I
know what I have to do I used to run
marathons I run the Boston Marathon and
I know what it took the Train and I'm
not you know I don't run like that
anymore i Stairmaster but I mean I we
all know how to lose weight we all know
how to get physically fit we all know
how to build our businesses I can go to
the Yellow Pages today and pick out any
business that's in this room and I can
find somebody that's beating your brains
out I don't care what you do
and as some of you have heard me say but
I'm gonna say it again because it's
important for this example again we're
all have 100 IQ for some of you I'm
giving you some for some I'm taking away
some we all know nobody can have 10
times our IQ well then why the hell do
people make 10 times more than we do a
thousand times more than we do why
because they think and dream bigger than
we do high-performance people have high
expectations not average expectations
rule number 20 don't overthink things
Matthew and I were discussing some of
the things about why you've discounted
on a subconscious level some of the
things have happened because absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence and
he said there's something very profound
for an Australian this is heavy duty but
he said I decided to do it even though
it was stupid I decided to do it
stupid meaning the follow the process to
an intellectually bright guy who's an
engineer
and see you won't you you see you'll
figure out a better way and he followed
the stupid process that works and has
been working for 45 years 20-some years
before when I was doing it in 22 years
since I've been coaching and he called
it he wasn't trying to be insulting or
anything he says I just decided to
follow that you know how did you say
instead of trying to be smart
I would just try to be stupid shut that
part of my brain and just do it and what
happens he did it and that's why it's
hard for the youtubers and all the other
because you can't dumb you know dumb
down you won't you will not believe that
it's easy you can't you know you won't
it but he put it very succinctly
you know he just dumbed down and shut
off that part of his brain and just
followed the steps
you don't need case studies you have a
you have a template you have a script
that a monkey can read that Alex wants a
case study because he wants to know this
behind it because he's stupid
and that's why Spore you don't need in
him in case studies how many times do I
have to say you had the script I said
don't change a word on the script not a
comma if it's got misspelled and won't
send it out misspell the last thing you
need is a case study this is why you're
poor this is why the sucker watching
this on YouTube were so poor
rule number 21 keep on going when I was
a kid they said I was [ __ ]
they stood me in the corner with a dunce
cap but if people know what a dunce cap
is you know okay and if I turned around
they put me in the closet kept me there
for five six hours are urinated on
myself I my pants until my parents came
to pick me up now just imagine if that
had happened to you
but I used it it's not what happens to
you in life it's how you interpret what
happens
I made it made me stronger tougher
smarter most people would just collapse
when I play football American football
the coach Roy Jay may he rest in
roasting hell where every years he says
pinna you're something slow you oughta
wear the other team's Jersey do you
understand what that means you're such a
poor athlete
put the other Kings jersey on you no
good for us but I kept on going hitting
that land boom you don't want to have
the tackling exercise one guy in the
middle and everybody just said I was
that guy every day
if that had happened to you I know what
you do some of you would have committed
suicide that it made me stronger
yes I'm 601 225 a twisted steel and
Panther pissed at age 73
but I endured all this stuff rule number
22 don't care what others think rumor is
that I'm following in the footsteps of
two of my mentors and for those of you
that aren't bright enough to know that
that's Lenin and Stalin and me there's
some truth to that
because I believe in the old Russian way
I'm not interested in your opinions
that's the last thing I need is your
opinion is if your opinion was so good
you wouldn't be here and if you look at
my Hall a wall of influencers they're
both on there amongst some other people
like the devil and a few others Hitler
renumber 23 don't be an expert at least
two or three of you have asked me
privately on one-on-one or during the
breaks you know I was thinking about
going into such and such but I don't
want to know anything about such and
such how can I do it remember I knew not
enough about the oil and gas business to
fill the top of that pen I knew less
than and by anybody's imagination or
statistics or benchmarks
I was super successful and as I said
earlier a couple days ago now
unfortunately I know a lot about the
industry and I haven't made any money in
it in a number of years I want to you
know I haven't because now I look at the
deals man oh I mean the ratio between
gas and oil and this and that and supply
and demand so now I'm an expert I've
made a diamond it in 10-15 years
because now I look at it the wrong way
I look at it even though I don't do
spreadsheets I look at it in the
spreadsheet manner and I come up you can
always come up with a reason why not to
do something and by god I've come up
with a number of them over the year in
Orland gas rule number 24 be tough as
nails mr. Carnegie with
hard bastard Vanderbilt was a hard
bastard Henry Ford the first was a hard
bastard Rockefeller was a hard bastard
Steve Jobs was a ruthless hard bastard
as Apple's CEO Cooke regularly begins
sending emails at 4:30 in the morning on
Sunday he's a hard bastard why are all
these guys they changed the world got
one thing in common take the prisoners
and then we got you a stiff drink and a
good kill most people in this room I'm
ashamed to say and fast forget the stiff
drink just a good my proceeds from
paypal acquisition were 80 180 million
ba-ba-ba-ba then I had a borrow money
for rent these guys myself included are
all in if they believe what they're
doing they put all their money at risk
on which I have several times not in
recent years SpaceX worker reveals a
brutal company motto motto helped him
survive all-nighters working for Elon
Musk notorious workaholic Elon Musk is
so tied to his office that he's been
known to sleep on the floor I slept on
the floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor day slept on the floor success
leaves Clues you weenies
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had at work in 35 years
rule number 25 just do it best advice I
ever got from mister Grasso's do it he
didn't say just do it he didn't swear
and the best advice I've ever given
anybody is just do it we take too much
time procrastinating we take too and
because we're afraid of failure and fear
is false expectations appearing real
we're worried about what other people
think we're trying to fit in and I can
go through a whole litany of [ __ ]
not it's not [ __ ] it's not true
litany of stuff why you are where you
are because you just didn't do it you
didn't want to make a mistake you got a
mortgage you got a two ex-wives you got
a 15 year old daughter who's pregnant I
know you're your dad's got Alzheimer's
your mother's got emphysema spitting up
blood I can go on and on and on and on
but the bottom line is if you had 15
years ago you had just done it 10 years
ago you just done it five years ago if
you just done it six months ago if you
just done it you probably wouldn't be in
the position you're in now so I'm saying
no matter what your age is it's still
time to just go out and do it just go
out and do it
rule number 26 be a warrior this is what
I'm training you to be like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse warriors not
whiners not warriors do you think Donald
Trump is a whiner do you think he
worries and gives up what you think of
them do you think
I must gives up what you think of them
do you think the late Steve Jobs gives
it gave up what you thought of him do
you think Bill Gates gives up and I go
on and on and on the only one that gives
us what you and you and you and the
morons on YouTube rule number 27 leave
your comfort zone most of you have not
attained material wealth because you've
stayed in your comfort zone every family
has a aunt an uncle a grandfather then
went out lost the family fortune right
Uncle Harry crazy Harry you lost twenty
thousand fifty thousand a million
whatever the number is
well that resonates in you in your brain
your little pea brain and then you hear
another one your roommate in college
he's got an uncle Harry so pretty soon
the only input that you have is people
losing their family fortune that affects
you ie you then live within your comfort
zone
ie you don't take risks a tortoise a
turtle can only move forward when it
sticks its head and its feet out and
when it sticks its head and its feet out
its most vulnerable right biggest risk
most of you have lived a bubble-wrap
life most of you have been risk-averse
risk-averse to the extent there are
people beyond my comprehension they get
all the way through high school
we've never been screamed at never been
slapped never been in a fight never been
reprimanded by their parents and then
look at them snowflakes snowflakes
meaning they melt under pressure and
when I say that world is through look at
you the reason why the aliens haven't
come down to take it why why are they
gonna learn anything no rule number 28
love what you do it is simple can
everybody in this room do it no because
everybody in this room is not willing to
make the sacrifices I don't know how to
do it four hour work week which came up
a little earlier I don't know and I know
Ferriss and if you believe the 4-hour
workweek I've had a bridge to sell you
in New York I mean one of the comments
from the seminar that just ended from
the 1820 kids all of which were about
half my age
we had a couple of old gits in their 40s
but most of them were less than 30 they
commented at breakfast the last day
which was a Saturday or Sunday they said
how can he still be so fired up running
on two hundred percent of all the
cylinders when he's been on his feet 15
hours a day for six seven eight days and
we've been sitting on our arses and
we're tired and he's not you know why
because I and if you don't find
something that you love what you do
don't bother because if you don't have a
passion for what you do and your love it
gets old I say this stretching a little
it's like a significant other that
you've been around too much you know
what I mean everybody in this room can
relate to that I think ok well if you're
not
passionate about what you do in life it
gets old and then it becomes work and as
soon as it becomes work you're finished
the reason why I'm fired up at the end
of a six seven day week of 15 18 hours a
day is because I'm passionate about
pulling you sorry asses across the goal
line because that's my goal in life now
to pull as many of the sorry individuals
on the planet across the goal line as I
can before they put dirt on me
rule number 29 turn your life into a
process I want to take because you think
life is a journey that is horseshit
life's a journey if you're a [ __ ] and
you're [ __ ]
that's why you're not so that's what
you've done with the life up here too
far it's been a journey and how good is
the journey you tell me wouldn't you
rather when the first time you went out
with somebody that you thought you're in
love with thought is the operative word
once you've lied to have a template oh
let's follow this process instead of
because that is a journey and all the
mistakes you made and raising this
little kid for kids you got instead of
having this book wife doesn't have to be
a journey it's a journey for morons do
you think life is a journey for the
Trump kids that's a process the same
process his daddy raised him by saying
for me life ain't a journey who fear my
kid
it's a goddamn process so you tell me if
your results orientate it at all who's
better off the journey or the process
rule number 30 seize the opportunity
right now
on November 8 I announced that when mr.
Trump whether you love him or hate him
this was the beginning of the greatest
transformation of wealth the world has
ever seen
since World War two now what are you
what are you going to tell your kids and
your grandkids 25 years from now when
they say gee daddy gee grandpa what were
you doing other than having your thumb
up your ass
during the greatest transformation of
wealth and the history of the world what
were you doing oh nothing that's what
most of you will tell them your
grandchildren and your children it's
never going to get any better than this
kids this is the eyes I said on YouTube
the eye of the perfect storm this is it
I never thought I'd live to see it again
this is going to make the 80s look like
a nursery rhyme which I praise Allah
praise Buddha praise God
I participated and slashing and raping
everybody in the 80s legally this is
going to make that look like a nursery
rhyme and what are you going to tell
your kids oh I had a spreadsheet I had
to think about how to read another book
on M&A you morons
rule number 31 surround yourself with
greatness
the first method for estimating the
intelligence of a ruler is to look at
the man who surrounds himself with now
if I were going to judge you or you or
you by the guys you hang with the guys
you kill with I think you're a [ __ ]
you hanging to Bill Gates does not chill
he does not go to the Super Bowl Steve
Jobs didn't hang why do you
you hang out with monkeys a lot of
resemblance here you know you become a
circus show me your friends and I'll
show your future most of you would be
embarrassed to tell me who your five
closest buddies are rule number 30 to
minimize your regrets I didn't know I
had this in common with the founder of
Amazon but he's in the regret
minimization business he is modeled his
life styled what will I regret when I'm
80 now that he's 50 something he says
now it's going to be 90 same as me
but I've had 80 for a long long time and
there's still some things if I have
three regrets one I'm a combat trained
army officer they never saw combat to
that the day before my mother died at
here at the castle I'm screaming at her
god damn it don't be a [ __ ] or not sick
you're not gonna die next morning she's
dead can't go back on that Canyon and
the third is I didn't set my goals high
know nothing about missing my son or my
daughter's sweet 16 or missing a soccer
or a baseball game but none of that that
you have been led to believe wrongfully
are important I am a world-class eulogy
gripper and every single person I've
buried I normally go to seeing but
normally they asked me for it they die I
go and I said well what do you know what
do you want me to say and they always
say I'm sorry for it I didn't take this
risk I didn't do this I didn't do that
not that I missed my son's wedding not
that I miss my third grandchild birth
all that sloppy toppy that's the risk
they didn't take Adolf Hitler might be
the highest performance guy that ever
was born on the planet he got beat
performance doesn't mean you're a good
guy he got more done with less than any
human being ever he got more done with
less a little chicken private Austrian
from the second world war to be
Chancellor of the fatherland
so I mean when I say it I mean it's a
compliment not all the bad things he did
but I mean from from some nothing to
something he's a high-performance guy
rule number 34 press the envelope I am
mostly titanium and steel parts this is
me
artificial shoulders artificial
collarbone artificial knees full knees
artificial hip I've been busted up over
the years I do a lot of extraordinary
things not the least of which getting
run over by a buffalo 25 years ago but
I'm always pressing the envelope
physically and mentally and financially
ie we started the boxing ring which as I
told some of you in the beginning
95% of everybody thought it was a great
idea 5% said that I was inhumane like
the gladiators and the Lions and all
kind of bullsh and I've continued to
press myself now this is a 2014 we're in
New Zealand and I see a poster about
bungee jumping and I said I was telling
I got to do that instead I just turn
around and it's right here this is where
the bungee doesn't so I got to do that
so the next morning I said I'm in line
there's about 50-60 Millennials kind of
like you guys and they're all saying the
winds were gusting 40 to 60 miles an
hour and you can't jump so all the
millenniums ago when that wind dies down
I'm gonna jump that I'm gonna jump
they're all dancing around so I waited
about 10 minutes I take $100 bill I walk
up to the head of the line I said don't
you think that the winds die down now he
said I believe it is Hesser I jump okay
I come back these guys are still saying
without well your duty jump I didn't
know the wind died down but when it dies
down the next how I'm gonna jump down
some of those guys are still in line
waiting
rule number 35 find mentors you only
have one time to make a first impression
the first impression is how you look now
I already know how I look and you know
how I look as well
second impression is when you open your
mouth most of you with the greatest
respect can't speak properly you stutter
your mumble you sweat and I can go on
and on
I've learned it like the hot lights
because I want to convey my message so
you go where there are people that you
want to be like you find somebody that
is in my whole basis is mentorship find
somebody is where you want to be twenty
or thirty years from now and go to him
or her now
and I had the presence of mind to be
attracted to some very very famous very
well wealthy people in my 50-year career
and I went after them to not not for
money not for anything like that but I
just wanted him to talk to me and to
share their wisdom
rule number 36 build good habits
excellence is not a single act it's a
habit and right now most of you have
piss-poor habits and most of the kids on
YouTube have piss-poor habits because
your habits have been based on what
you've seen first of all how your
parents acted second of all how the
people that you've been exposed to
hanging with show me your friends and
I'll show you a future and the if you in
your neighborhood you know most of the
kids are getting arrested going to jail
going to prison there's a high
probability that you're gonna get
arrested and you're gonna go to jail and
you go to prison
rule number 37 take action what are you
gonna tell your children what are you
going to tell your grandchildren 20
years from now daddy grandpa what were
you doing doing the greatest
transformation the wealth and the
history of the planet although having
your stomach yes what are you gonna tell
him oh I was thinking about it I was
spread yet I'm proud to say I haven't
done a spreadsheet in 10-15 years
don't read another book
go listen to another read a blog listen
to a podcast
rule number 38 wanted died enough as a
hip-hop motivational guy a black guy
yeah and he says if you don't want to be
successful as much as you want lungs
breath in your lungs now that you
qualify in this room
hardly anybody to come to the seminar
quantifies when I was doing this and
when I invented qlae and didn't know was
kill away at the time only knew it was
too late when I look back and I put it
together the models if you will or the
formula I wanted it more than air I
sacrifice my God my country my family my
children my parents my friends and guess
what it happened rule number 39 be an
eagle eagles fly alone I have no friends
friends are problems friends are
challenges if you can if you aren't into
yourself and that means something else
now that what I mean if you're not into
yourself enough that you can't spend the
weekend by yourself and your something's
wrong with you
visa vie self-esteem being a
high-performance person and
accomplishing the high performance acts
something's wrong with you
rule number 40 dream big a guy I was a
barrio bad boy in the barrio of East Los
Angeles to the guns me that's a big lead
that's a big big it doesn't I can't
imagine
well came close last year I was honoured
by the Queen of England I am now as they
call a member of st. John a member of
st. John which is just but look thank
you thank you and it's a derivative of
Templar the people that supposedly took
Christ's body died at Island you know
the Knights of the Templar that's what
it is
but for kidding me East LA who almost
killed his teacher
now was I thinking about killing the
teacher no I was up on the Youth Club
the second floor with a query him and I
looked down at the teacher and the
teacher it pissed me off and back in
those days I wasn't the kind of guy
you'd want to piss off so I dropped the
aquarium wait 45 pounds by the grace of
God are labuda he moved and it didn't
hit him in the head to hit him in the
shoulder and crushed his shoulder right
clavicle if that had killed him back in
the mid-50s I wouldn't be sitting here
Oh Quinn want to give me anything not
even a postage stamp and i wouldnt be
living in a castle because i would
expect a larger majority of my adult
life in prison
rule number 41 always play to win
am i number of you who started a
business at one time in a lot in your
life the first 50,000 100,000 euros in
revenue when you start is geometric
growth so everybody that has ever
started a business generated any income
that's a geometric growth because it's
starting from the ground zero to the
first 50 100 everybody with me okay what
happens you stop playing to win and you
start playing not to lose if when not if
but when you decide that you really want
to invoke permanent change you start
playing to win all the time and nobody
preaches that they say keep six months
reserved in your bank account right in
case you lose your job that's that's a
common [ __ ] for the first 30 years
of my life I spent 125 percent of every
penny that I made every year I was
always as you would say in depth instead
of debt I don't know why I called a dip
at any in depth why because I didn't
want any backup I didn't want any Plan B
I either succeeded or die financially
rule number 42 have high standards qlae
works for not just money this kid came
to me two years ago he had never
finished higher than 20th and university
archery he was on the archery team in
Britain never finished higher than
twentieth and any meat he'd ever
attended
this is him finishing first in great
a year and a half later first the little
skinny wimp [ __ ]
he couldn't even pull the thing back I
didn't realize you know they've got 60
pound bows so he goes and get a 140
pound bow
well he doesn't weigh 140 pounds
finished first he was firing 50 to 100
arrows I said you fire 500 arrows a day
for the next year and you'll win his
little arms would quiver couldn't get
the thing back blisters cut through his
hands he's the champ now your goal has
got to be high standards I talked to a
couple of kids and financial planning
kids here and I happen to know a lot
about financial planning being one of
the forerunners 50 years ago and most of
the kids are going to that wealth
management as it's called now don't set
the standards high enough you don't want
to manage money for people that have two
or five or ten million you want a man
money for people that have a hundred
five hundred in a billion but they don't
teach you that during the training
programs at Merrill Lynch Goldman Sachs
at center et cetera because they
realized that only one in a hundred is
going to attain that goal and they want
a hundred of you with five million in
your book not one of you with a billion
in your book
rule number 43 focus on the few not the
many folks on you not the many and I've
been given that advice for 25 years and
I was given that advice when I was with
the Onassis people and we think we think
about too many different things and we
try to do too many things virtually
everybody almost everybody in the group
is trying to do too many things and the
and the most successful not unlike you
Josh you focus
once you've pivoted on one thing until
you got the ball across the goal line
until you got the deal financed and
until you get the actual money financed
and the exchange contracts as it's
called in this country the deals not
over too
fat lady sings until it's over and I see
you gave it an example being on the one
inch line two or three times and I see a
lot of kids falter at the one-inch line
the either because they're working on
something else or they allow something
else to obstruct their ultimate goal
rule number 44 work hard Jack Welsh
arguably the greatest CEO in the history
of the world who managed in General
Electric for 20-25 years he said there
was no work-life balance there worth
work life challenges and we make
decisions and we live with him do you
think Elon Musk has worked life balance
no do you think Steve Jobs when he was
alive had work-life balance no do you
think Bill Gates no Henry Ford no
original Heineken no so if none of those
people that created the wealth of the
world had work-life balance why do you
think you're gonna have it why could you
deserve it I don't think so you deserve
what you get in life by working hard
rule number 45 be tough I drove by a
college today and yelled boo 35 people
went to the hospital 734 needed crisis
counseling 429 needed a safe area or
room and classes were cancelled for a
week there are universities that I've
spoken at that have safe floors the
third floor and the physics building in
Cracow University has a safe floor if
life gets too tougher than they go to
that floor to chill the Air Force
Academy has safe parts when there went
yeah we have a Naval Academy guys so he
said that they pull when they're being
beat up too much enlisted man going
through boot camp have safe cards that
they pull or luckily we don't go to war
with Russia
they'll eat our lunch
they're gonna eat us alive we're lucky
there are no safe cards and life I tell
the kids all the time if we're at war
we'd all be dead see you're used to
making mistakes and nothing happens for
the few of you in the military in here
you know mistakes and cost lives my our
kids are Millennials but they're not I
mean you'd think that they were Godzilla
a tiller of the Han and Genghis Khan
compared to them other Millennials our
daughter is me with a skirt she's a
rough she's a rough girl daddy why do
you want to go if she were standing here
she said my daddy treats everybody the
same like whether you're the Pope
although I do cut the pump some slack
that's not quite accurate whether you're
you know whoever I mean I treat
everybody the same
because I hold everybody accountable if
you tell me you're gonna do something
young lady if you don't do it I'll rip
your head off down your neck I'll be all
over you like like like a cheap suit
rule number 46 be willing to make
sacrifices as seven and a half billion
people on the planet and my my
guesstimate is world there's only about
seven or eight hundred thousand of us on
the planet that are willing to make the
sacrifices of these the focused
commitment and it's just like a premier
athletes you know there's a lot of
people that run $100 - but there's very
few of them that make it the Olympics
and there's even a fewer that matter
rule number 47 love yourself first I
love myself
nobody my wife got god bless you would
say I
I worship the ground don't get mad at me
Sally I worship the ground dan walks on
but my love for him is transitory for
the love he has for himself self-esteem
if you don't love yourself you can't be
a good husband a good father or good
anything love you first and I have no
problem and I've been that way even when
I was doing bad things
rule number 48 have a dream now this is
me my best attempt to be a cholo in East
LA
that was taken 25 years ago and find out
where my house used to be and if you can
tell my house was from the chain-link
fence to the brick wall wasn't very big
house was it was 800 square feet when we
were taking that picture in 1993 there
was two drive-by shootings within the
neighborhood and my camera guys jumped
under the car
that's why I come from this is where I
lived in 1972 on Wall Street 14 years
later I think it was 12 years later I
lived there I lived in little they used
to call him when they had no I forgot
what they call but anyway a little
apartment I had III lived in a place
called the bedbug bedford but we call it
the beg bug because carceral cockroaches
were that big qualen we used to sit
there and watch our little TV and we'd
see the cockroaches racing back and
forth the floor six of us in a
two-bedroom apartment
and in 12 years not dissimilar to
President Obama I had a dream that I was
going to live in a castle on an island
and 12 years later I moved in
rule number 49 dress well dressed like
the president of the prime minister of
your country you only have one time to
make the first impression kids
you're coming looking like some of you I
wouldn't give you Tyla paper most of you
I'd be embarrassed to wear dress and
rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is just do you
the 50 billion dollar man that guy yes
yes he doesn't give a [ __ ] though yeah
that's what it was almost dead I don't
think we could play his stuff without
getting sued Jamie hello Joe
my name is dan pena I'm still affordable
force at 6 1 2 25 and if you think that
I'm almost dead and I'm not gonna be
alive anymore ask this bear that I
killed with a knife not too long ago I'm
still a very tough guy at 71 I take no
Bush in person or on the youtubes I'm
not dead and I'm plenty alive and I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says
about me I rip people's head off and
down their neck and from one tough guy
to another tough guy don't be afraid
don't be scared to use my stuff on your
podcast it's all free you asked me why
do you give it away free Dan I give it
away free to take the last excuse away
from the sorry why they can't fulfill
their dreams I'm calling you out Joe you
think you're a tough guard you haven't
met me on the fifty billion dollar man
and this is my lair
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus cup from
Dan on how to keep an open mind that I
really think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing question it's time to go
from just watching another video to
taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
raise your standards number two what new
good habit do you need to build and
number three whose opinion of you do you
need to let go of if you are not
experiencing anxiety if your problems
are not replaced as soon as you saw one
with a bigger one that's geometrically
bigger then you're not growing I hate to
hear people tell me my business is
running smoothly everything's great well
then you might as well or she might as
well blow their brains out because it
sure as hell aren't growing what my deal
is all about is growing geometrically
quantumly and just remember that and
keep an open mind because I have been
there and done that there's no question
about that yeah yeah another thing I
said this yesterday just because you
haven't done it just because you've
never been around somebody that hasn't
done that hasn't done it and just
because you've never heard of it doesn't
mean it doesn't exist because absence of
evidence is not evidence of their
absence I'm going to say some things
that are real foreign to you some things
that you've been taught by your parents
your grandparents in school and
basically all that is crap now I'm not
talking about moral issues and things
like that a religion I don't get into
that I was raised a Roman Catholic if
that desi and I'm still a Roman Catholic
and my wife's a convert Catholic if that
gives you any idea about where I stand
on religion but I'll be glad to debate
any that during the break so just keep
an open mind the high-performance people
that I will continue to allude to all
day long live in a different world than
you they came from the same world as you
did but they live in a different world
they think differently and if you want
more Dane Payne
check out the one-on-one interview I did
with him the link is right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I'm a barrio bad boy it came from
the barrio beast Los Angeles as a
adolescent gotten a lot of trouble